let's now start thinking about counting
the number of ways to do something or
the number of ways to arrange things and
so let's say we're at a small dinner
party and there are four people at the
dinner party let's say there's person a
person
b
person c
and person d
and they all want to be polite and they
all want to meet each other let's say
they've never met each other before and
so they're all going to shake each
other's hands that each person wants to
shake the hand of all of the other
dinner guests
so the question is how many handshakes
are going to occur if we assume that
each person is going to shake each other
person's hand exactly once and i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it and then we can we can
count out the scenarios together
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
one way to think about it is well each
person let's say person a
person a is going to shake how many
hands so you could say person a is going
to shake the hands of person b person c
and person d so person a is going to
engage in three handshakes you can make
the same argument that person b
is also going to engage in three
handshakes he's going to shake person a
c and d's hands
you could argue that person c she'll
also engage in three handshakes she'll
she'll shake the hands of of a b and d
and then likewise person d is going to
engage in three handshakes so in total
you have four people each engaging in
three handshakes so you have four people
each engaging in three handshakes so you
have 12 handshakes
so my question to you is
do you feel good
do you feel good about this number pause
the video and try to think about it
so let's let's actually draw it out
let's actually draw all of the
handshakes i kind of went through this
this argument fairly fast but i actually
want to want to visually represent each
handshake that goes on so let's talk
about all of the handshakes that a
engages in so a is going to shake b's
hand
a is going to shake
c's hand a is going to shake d's hand so
it still seems consistent with what we
have here but let's keep going
we're then
saying
that b
is going to shake a's hand
b is going to shake c's hand and b is
going to shake d's hand and let's keep
going
then we have
c
c is going to shake a
c is going to shake b
c is going to shake d
and then we have
and then we have
d is going to shake a's hand d is going
to shake b's hand and d is going to
shake c's hand and you're probably
saying oh sal you just listed exactly 12
things
but there's something interesting here
we are double counting and i encourage
you to pause the video and think about
where are we double counting
so i'm assuming you've had another go at
it but the realization remember we're
saying that each person shakes each
other guest's hand exactly once so this
is a and b shaking their hands but this
is also a and b shaking their hands so
we have double counted this it's no
different if b is shaking a's hand then
a is shaking b's hand this is exactly
one handshake likewise a shaking c
and c shaking a
this is the same i guess we could say
this is we're either saying that these
are two handshakes even though this
we're saying that people should only
shake their hands once so we're double
counting likewise want this one
and this one
this we are
we are
double counting the way that we've
described it
so if we're double counting what should
we do this number 12 well we should just
divide it by two we should just divide
it by two once again over here we're
counting when a shakes d hands over here
we're counting where d shakes a a sand
but that's really the same thing so for
double counting and we want to get the
right thing let's divide by two and so
four times three divided by two is 12
divided by two we get a total of six
six handshakes
and if we want to see the six handshakes
right here let's get rid of all the
double counting so a b is the same thing
as this one so let's get rid of that ac
is the same thing as that one a d is the
same thing as this one
b c is the same thing as this one
b d is the same thing as this one and cd
is the same thing as
dc so we are left with we're left with
one two three four
five
six total handshakes